[Music]
they remember here every year but this
centenary it was different
world leaders walked together down the
Shawn's alizée shoulder-to-shoulder
under the rain to the Arc de Triomphe
and Frances Tomb of the Unknown Soldier
the French president wanted this to be a
reflection on the past but a moment to
ponder the future - a flyover marked the
start of an hour-long ceremony and in
driving rain the American president and
first lady were here a day after weather
had caused them to cancel the visit to a
u.s. cemetery outside Paris the Russian
President was the last to arrive with
handshakes and a thumbs up for Donald
Trump
young students of an age that could have
compelled them to fight a hundred years
ago read the testimony of those who did
the streets were packed with wildly
cheering civilian damage in the
periphery to be in the parade were
hundreds of thousands of soldiers from
the US England Canada France Australia
Italy and economies give me the owner
Tim one president macron spoke for 15
minutes weaving the past together with
the present least well man I know former
demons are resurfacing ready to carry
out their work of chaos and death new
ideologies are manipulating religions
spreading confusion our tragic story
sometimes threatens to repeat itself and
compromise our country's peace this
really felt like a global reflection so
many nations who lost so many in Belgium
in eeep the men in gate was the focus
through the war through this town
hundreds of thousands of soldiers
marched east to the battlefields of
Flanders
the names of 50 4896 of those who didn't
return and whose bodies were never found
a cut into the Portland stone some half
a million soldiers from all sides died
in the fields around here 100 years on
relatives of many returned to remember
[Music]
my great-grandfather died back in France
the weather did allow this time for a
visit by the American president to
another US War Cemetery
Suren on the western edge of Paris thank
you for joining us as we honor the
American and French service members who
shed their blood together in a horrible
horrible war some 16 million people were
killed in the four years of fighting 100
years on their flame still burns mark
stone Sky News in Paris